[Musique]
bien sûr j'avais un doudou mais tous
calcutta sais que tu sais le chiffon
dégueulasse et que tu ne supportes pas
que ta maman passe à la machine parce
qu'il à tournon d'heure en fait voilà
évidemment mon kiki de toul et qui nous
donne cette panthère qui dormait avec
moi était largement imprégnée de pipi et
un jour ma mère quand même a décidé à
elle avait écrit il ya en fait allé plus
en odeur m'en suis jamais servi au lieu
dit ma soeur ma plaie trois grosses
vaches sont des vrais traumatisme
d'enfance là mais césar par ma mère
gilles au but et j'ai loupé bungie est
plutôt que de tout comme je répète
agathe la touffe ne le retenait part
j'ai toujours voulu être journaliste à 8
ans je voulais être journaliste donc
cette race était au stade vélodrome en
1972 edition journée dans sport je
voulais être magicien pour un tel droit
vers l'âge de 11 12 ans arthur qui m'a
donné envie de faire de la télé j'ai
toujours voulu être entertainer quoi tu
vas
c'était dorothée celle qui m'a donné
envie de faire de la télévision j'en ai
eu deux vraiment dans ma jeunesse joseph
lambert camaro camaro j'avais des
posters de camaro à 100 mais je te jure
mon idole dont j'étais amoureuse tu veux
vraiment savoir je les chèques son
affiche au dessus de mon lit je le les
chats littéralement ulysse 31 ministre
vien accord unit musicale avec julien
clerc je mettais les cassettes et
chantal and the sunshine chamayou donne
moi ton coeur béret donne moi ton corps
bébé je mets le doigt demande mais loin
derrière stade mathon bongo fin demain
tu auras beau matin sol tu viens le
doigt devant je fais de tout boutiron
d'années l'homme sauf cette can
gadio fait du bout du monde veulent tous
le moi même
la compagnie créole ce soir c'est ma
boum c'est ma folie c'est ma toute
première begin parti tu as connu ça bien
sûr
[Musique]
je jouais au foot au tennis ballon
j'étais très fort parce que j'ai une
peau me casser la mer du fait main sinon
je peux casser la table à l'élastique
tonton l'élastique à l'élastique les
critiques c'est sympathique et épique le
championnat c'est pour demain mais
j'étais une championne du monde
élastique
si si